[Music]
pete joe congratulations you've made it
into the final now we're sending you
back to your home forges where you will
have to forge an iconic blade from
history are you ready to see what that
weapon is oh yeah
yes absolutely
[Music]
is a two-handed sword carried into
battle by the diax a group of tribes
that lived on the island of borneo for
thousands of years though most dayak
weapons doubled his useful tools the
pandat was only used in war forced from
iron the pandat features an angled blade
and can be swung downwards with two
hands an iron cross piece was inserted
through a hole at the end of the handle
protecting the user's hand the blade was
sometimes decorated with hair or rattan
plant until the early 20th century dayak
raiders plundered coastal settlements
for resources money and even enemy heads
proving just how deadly this weapon
could be
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days
this is home jinx oklahoma
it's gonna be hot it's gonna be humid
but i'm not worried about anything other
than an accident or the unforeseen
i mean have never seen this blade i've
never even heard of it a little
apprehensive about building it
five days it seems like a lot of time
but to build a piece like this it's
gonna be really really hard
come on stay with me don't don't power
out on me
what's going on
oh wow
i haven't seen a rain this hard in a
long time y'all i mean this is this is
kind of intense
oh
okay
okay
yeah boys
damn it
go go go
where you're at do not move
midway through day one everything's
going great
and boom
amazing storm hits i mean this thing was
unreal there was some damage done we had
a lot of trees down took out of course
the the meter and the power lines
doesn't look like we're going to get
power back any time soon so we're going
to get a generator we're going to get it
pumped up we'll get power and juice back
in the shop and then we're going to move
forward
yay
we have power
and this was a pretty good setback
it's reality check to go hey
you sure you got what it takes to do
this
today is day three
and i've been told it's saturday
[Music]
it's gonna be a cutting test of a
strength test that's gonna be a keel
test too so i wanna draw my spine back
so it's a little softer so it's got a
little bit of flex so i rigged up kind
of an ancient way to do it i've dug a
trench to keep the edge
cool so it it won't get soft
i've really been fighting the wind with
it but as fast as you get it warmed up
it cools down
i also have to keep water in the trench
when you've got a
very hot torch blasting against the
water it evaporates rather quickly
i'm not sure i'm going to get it done
day four either we top the hill or we
roll down another one today's a make or
break day for this blade we're gonna
quench this thing and uh hope for the
best and hopefully your best is good
enough
doing this is about as nerve-wracking as
it gets
you just want everything to go nice and
smooth
it did harden
but i got crazy ass warpage right there
it's a bit of a kick in the pants we're
running out of time grind grind grind
that's what it's going to come down to
and hopefully get that warp out
[Music]
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
to see how sharp your weapons are i will
attempt to cut through these web of
ropes with three identical strikes if
they're sharp i should meet no
resistance
joey up first you ready let's do it
[Music]
well joe
all the weight is at the tip of the
blade so when i come down it wants to
draw me forward and the recovery is a
little bit harder on the way back
you have a sharp edge over here that i
almost meant
no resistance
overall sir your blade
will cut
pete you're up next you ready
yes sir let's do this
okay pete it is a sharp blade the
balance
is light you have a lighter blade here
it's not as heavy to pull forward it's a
good job the only issue i have
is that i kind of ran out of handle here
i would have liked to see a little
pummel here or probably even a longer
handle so it's easier to control and not
feel like i'm at the end of my rope
so to say
overall this weapon sir will cut
thank you
all right bladesmiths next up is a kill
test
now the pandat was a weapon used by
headhunting tribes in borneo to see how
lethal your weapon is i will take your
pandat and i will deliver one blow
to this carcass
let's see how much damage your weapon
can do joe you're up first you ready
let's bring it let's do it
[Music]
yeah
okay joe the balance feels so forward
heavy that when you slice through this
carcass it pulled me into it and cut
cleanly all the way through
this weapon sir will kill good job thank
you
peter up next you ready yes i am
[Music]
okay pete the difference with your blade
is that it's light and because it's
light i can use velocity to help cut
through this carcass
this weapon sir will kill
good job
thank you
all right gentlemen this is the strength
test to test the strength and durability
of your blades we're going to hook them
into our machine here which is going to
chop into this bundle of sugar cane
now if your blades are tempered properly
they should cut into the cane without a
problem
if not we might get them to bend warp
but we'll see what happens joe you're
already rigged up on the machine you
ready to go let's go all right let's do
this
all right joe
three
two one
right so joe now when i pulled this out
of the machine
there's a bit of a bend right here in
the ricasso kind of a gap
right along the edge of the blade in the
guard it had that warp when it got here
it had that warp when it got here
it was actually offset it's got a little
bit of a twist maybe a five degree twist
i couldn't get it out whenever i built
it well it may have gotten bigger during
that test
overall
the edge held up fine no damage
whatsoever
it's got a good shape good job
thanks sir all right pete you're all
locked in ready for this i am all right
all right pete
three
two
one
[Music]
all right pete and you could actually
see how much this blade
flexed when it went into the into the
cane
and came back to true which is always
what i want to see definitely sharp well
put together
feels good all right well done p
thank you
[Music]
gentlemen this is one of the tightest
competitions that we've had
it's exactly what we want from our
bladesmiths it was a difficult decision
but that final decision has been made
the forged and fire champion is
[Music]
pete congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion
joe
please surrender your weapon
this experience has taught me like many
things like to try
dare to fail if you fail so what
feeling kind of disappointed right now
but
at least i tried
[Music]
pete congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion and we'll be receiving
that check for 10 grand good job thank
you
[Applause]
repeat
what i really liked about your blade
amongst many things is you know i wanted
to grab that thing and cut something
with it and when i felt it
it i mean it gives you the woo to strike
you know it really does want to cut
how you feeling right now pete
you're pretty good
i'm feeling like i could just roll on
the floor and bust out laughing it feels
real good feels real good to win
i'm going home
the foraging fire champion
and i know all 24 of my grandkids are
going to be excited for grandpa
you